the focus very much now on this nuclear
plant and it's all quite concerning just
bring us up to speed yes and today has
been a big day for a while because the
Russians said 5th of July we want
everybody at the plant out they they
combed a lot of the Ukrainian workers
who were there and they seemed to be
pulling out of the plant and they told
people in anahada which is the is the
town around the plant to get out by the
5th of July so everybody's been thinking
that this was an important date and in
the last 36 hours a lot of tension is
built up on the telegram channels in
statements that have been made so the
Russians are saying that they think the
ukrainians will bombard the plant as
part of their offensive and the
ukrainians are saying that the Russians
have been planning to blow a couple of
uh reactors at the plant since the last
August and that's where we are today
we've reached what seems to be a
critical point so if there is some sort
of uh disaster heaven forbid how would
that come about do you think is it is it
likely well
um the argument is that the Russians
have actually put um charges in two of
six nuclear reactors so those are the
six reactors along there and reactors
three and four the middle two it is said
have been set with charges at the top of
those reactors that's the accusation now
those two reactors went offline uh just
over 24 hours ago in terms of the power
grid so the other four reactors are on
the main power grid those two are now on
auxiliary power for reasons unexplained
so there's something strange about
reactors three and four so the question
is um you know could it happen well yes
there could be explosions there would
the Russians do it they're certainly
trying to create the fear because they
think they can get something politically
out of creating fear of a nuclear
accident will they do it well
um they've done other things like it and
so I certainly wouldn't rule it out and
how bad could it be I mean we're looking
at something like Chernobyl again what
would it look like wouldn't probably be
as bad as Chernobyl it's this is a
different sort of reactor it's much
safer the the actual core is is much
safer it's encased in a better way and
they use hard oxide fuel which is not
the same Chernobyl it's not nor is it
the same as Fukushima in 1911 because
this has been quite cool for a while now
it's not before humor is very hot when
the disaster happened but zapparesia
itself uh the zap Regio city of course
is a different place to the power plant
I mean zaparies city is held by the
ukrainians the power plants on the other
side of the river held by the Russians
quite a long way away if there were an
explosion of course there is a danger of
some sort of contamination some sort of
nuclear cloud of some sort there
developing and then it would depend on
the weather and at the moment the wind
is very light and the wind is in the
South and Southwest so any any Fallout
if there were some would go towards the
Southwest but at the weekend on Saturday
Sunday the wind strength turns around to
the southeast and the due east and so it
would and there's quite a bit of rain in
the forecast which will damp things down
a bit so we're looking at the weather
we're looking at whether explosions will
create much of a plume that might not
but if they did then we'd be thinking
about where it would go okay and Michael
thank you very much